hello everyone welcome to another
episode of science and technology q a
for kids and others
so this is
uh i get to spend an hour here doing
something different from what i usually
do and answering whatever questions you
guys may have
about science and technology
uh try any kind of topic if i don't know
the answer i'll tell you i don't know
the answer
let's see we have a number of questions
that got saved up from previous times as
one from wardrobe asking do you think we
will get anti-gravity cars
let's talk about anti-gravity for for a
few minutes
so
what is gravity
gravity is fundamentally a force
that is exerted by
things that have mass
so the earth for example has a bunch of
mass
and it attracts through gravity
things towards it
now there's sort of an interpretation of
that that is a bit more than 100 years
old that comes from a general theory of
relativity that says what's happening is
that mass of the earth
is causing the very structure of space
to be distorted
and that means that something which if
the earth wasn't there something might
just if if you just started a spacecraft
off and there weren't and there was
nothing in the way it was just a vacuum
the spacecraft would just keep going in
a straight line forever same with a beam
of light
but
if what the this force of gravity is
associated with the fact that when there
is something which has mass
it distorts the structure of space it
curves space
so that what counts as a shortest path
which would usually be a straight line
ends up being a distorted path that
corresponds to something that will be
attracted as it's it's the equivalent of
being attracted towards the object
so sort of the big idea is gravity is
the result of distortions in space
having to do with the presence of mass
mass causes a distortion in space
okay in the usual theory
there are only positive masses that well
in in the in the mathematical theory of
general relativity
you can have a positive mass or you can
have a negative mass
but in our universe we only have
observed positive masses a positive mass
produces an attractive force of gravity
a negative mass would produce a
repulsive force of gravity
so for example if you wanted to make um
an anti-gravity car you would need
something which produces somehow
anti-gravity that has
a
that has the equivalent of negative mass
so there's a question of can there ever
be negative mass
in our universe
things we know electrons they have a
positive mass protons they have a
positive mass the anti-particles of
electrons positrons and the
anti-particles of protons antiprotons
they have a positive mass as well they
have their anti
because they have the opposite electric
charge but they have the same
gravitational charge the same mass both
positive
so is this question could you ever have
something with negative mass
well there are various detailed
experiments that have been done on the
expansion of the universe
and the
the expansion of the universe when there
is positive mass in the universe the
universe starts off in the big bang
starts off expanding rapidly more or
less the speed of light actually even in
some sense faster than speed of light
and some theories that i don't think are
quite correct
um but uh the universe is basically it's
sort of a big explosion and things start
going outwards at a certain speed
when there is mass in the universe when
there's enough mass in the universe that
the force of gravity will cause that
speed to slow down eventually the
universe might stop expanding might even
contract again and so on
actual measurements suggest that the
universe is not about to not going to
collapse instead perhaps it's even
expanding a little bit extra it's like
accelerating slightly in its expansion
so how do you get a universe that
accelerates in its expansion the answer
is you put in something with negative
mass in the universe
so that goes by the sort of brand name
of dark energy in modern cosmology and
dark energy is basically negative mass
stuff
and what is it
does it exist nobody knows
but it's something which the
experimental observations on the
expansion rate of the universe suggests
maybe should exist
now you might ask since
we've been working on a fundamental
theory of physics how do things like
negative mass show up in our fundamental
theory of physics
well
here's here's roughly how that works
so i've said gravity is a phenomenon
associated with essentially distortions
in space
but a big question in making a theory of
physics is what is space
and sort of the the story for the last
couple of thousand years has been space
is just a place where things get put
there's no question of what space itself
is
actually to be fair in ancient greek
times people did ask questions about
what space itself is
um but that kind of fell out of favor
when people had kind of mathematical
descriptions of just coordinates you
place something in a particular
coordinate position in space people
stopped asking what is space so to speak
and the analogy i tend to use is if you
think about fluid like water you might
say well it's just this thing that flows
and you can have a little drop of ink
anywhere in that water or whatever you
want
and you might say you don't have to say
you just have to say what the water does
you don't have to say what it's made of
but in fact we know that water is made
of discrete molecules and so for example
if we were to put that drop of ink or
some smaller thing and drop a [ __ ] in
different places around the water
there'd be some places we could put it
where there's actually a molecule and
some places where we sort of couldn't
put it because it's a space between
molecules
so the question is how does actual space
work
and
uh what we think very strongly is that
actual space is not just the sort of
background continuous thing where you
get to place coordinates wherever you
want instead space is made of stuff
we call them atoms of space they're
really just idealized geometrical points
and what happens in our theory is that
there's this giant number of trillions
and trillions of trillions and trillions
on trillions i've got to say many
trillions here to get the right number
10 to the 400 maybe roughly atoms of
space that make up our universe
and all that we can say about these
atoms of space is how each
one is kind of connected to others
there's no sort of physically known
connection it's just an abstract idea of
sort of a connection or relation between
atoms of space
it's it's as if we know what atom of
space is friends with what other atom of
space but we don't know anything else we
don't know how quotes far away they are
or anything we just know which one is
related to which other one so that giant
collection of relations connections
forms this giant network and that is the
structure of space
that structure of space
is what happens is just like water on a
small scale might be made of molecules
on a larger scale it seems like in
continuous fluid so it is with space
now there's a question if if space is
like that at a particular moment in time
how does it progress with time in our
models what happens is that locally in
every little region of that network if
the network has a particular form it
gets rewritten to another form it gets
rearranged into another form and that's
happening all over the universe all the
time the structure of space little
pieces of space are being rewritten as
other little pieces of space
in fact if it wasn't for that rewriting
activity space would just fall apart
there wouldn't be any connection between
different parts of space it's that
continued activity that kind of knits
together the structure of space
and in fact the the structure of space
most of the activity of the universe is
concerned with the netting together of
the act of the structure of space
things that we're used to like electrons
and photons and all those kinds of
things those are just little sort of
ripples on top of this kind of all this
activity of knitting together the
structure of space it's a little bit
like if you have a fluid and let's say
you have a vortex kind of a whirlpool
inside the fluid that's made of a whole
bunch of molecules going around but most
of what happens in the fluid is
molecules bouncing around
individual molecules uh colliding with
each other and so on that effect of the
kind of the vortex is a very tiny effect
relative to all the details of the
molecules bouncing around and so it is
with space the the knitting together of
the structure of space is by far the
dominant effect and the little sort of
vortices or whatever else that
correspond to the particles that we know
about and pay attention to in the
universe that's a tiny effect on top of
all of that
okay so
most of the time if there is turns out
in our models as one of the kind of
spectacular things that comes out is
that we can understand that sort of
additional activity in the structure of
space
is the equivalent of having mass or
energy in space and we can actually see
the force of gravity emerges in our
models it's just essentially a
mathematical in a sense computational
consequence of the structure of our
models it's not something we have to say
and then there is a law of gravity that
law emerges from the structure of our
models and essentially what happens is
when there is more activity in space
when there's more rewriting happening in
space
that will be the equivalence of of mass
and it will attract
paths of things uh nearby in space will
be attracted to that place and that
corresponds to the same kind of
curvature of space leading to gravity
that you see in general activity
okay having said that the question is
can there be anti-gravity
well what gravity is
in our models is in addition to all the
activity to do with knitting together
the structure of space there's some
additional activity that leads to the
things like electrons and so on that
have mass that we recognize so the
things we recognize all of us so to
speak are additional activity over and
above
the kind of background activity
associated with knitting together the
structured space
so
anti-gravity negative mass would
correspond to places where there's less
activity in the universe associated with
knitting together than there would be
from just the background of knitting
together the structure of space
do such things exist we don't know
is it theoretically possible in our
models that there could be regions where
the amount of activity knitting together
the structure of space is reduced yes it
is certainly possible in fact in very
extreme cases in the center of black
holes where there are actual
singularities in space-time what happens
in the center of the the most standard
kind of black hole is that in our models
i've talked about how space continually
gets rewritten that's the progress of
time there can be a situation in which
there's just no rewriting that can
happen and in that situation time
effectively ends and that's what happens
in the middle of the simplest kinds of
black holes is you have a place
where there is a structure to space but
time simply ends and so in a sense you
you you can't really discuss is space
nested together there because time has
ended
so
that's that's a case where in a sense
less is happening than you might think
would be happening in that particular
case time has ended
so is it possible that there are
situations in which less will be
happening in this underlying knitting
together of space than usual yes
possibly although i don't know specific
cases in which that would happen
so that's kind of the foundation that
one needs to make one's uh sort of
everyday anti-gravity car and we're
certainly very far away from
understanding how to hack space to
achieve something like that i actually
wrote a thing last year about the
question of whether you can travel
faster than light in the universe
and that
it is turns out that there is a way in
which you can imagine kind of hacking
space to travel faster than light the
only problem is that that hacking is
happening right down at the level of
individual atoms of space
which is a distance of trillion trillion
trillion trillion trillion trillionth
very very tiny vastly vastly tinier than
anything that we currently know how to
manipulate
but um that's sort of a coming
attraction for some number of centuries
from now perhaps that it might be
possible to hack the structure of space
now the real question is let's say you
hack the structure of space
to go faster than light which
as i say i could explain how that works
but but one can expect that that's
probably possible
the in some sense what's happening is
what's really happening is that
the
the structure of space
has a has a certain typical form
but there will be places where you can
have essentially these space tunnels
these fluctuations in the structure of
space and if you find exactly the right
fluctuation you can kind of hop from one
place in space to another
faster than a great big photon that's a
piece of light could get through space
it's kind of analogous to the following
thing in our
in air in this room it's a bunch of
molecules bouncing around the typical
molecule goes only a tiny fraction of a
centimeter before it collides with
another molecule and which then
randomizes its direction and so on but
if you could pick the exact right
sequence of molecules to ride on so to
speak you would be able to go from one
side of the room to the other basically
the speed of sound
as it is the molecules will bounce off
each other they'll bounce in the wrong
direction they'll go in this way they'll
go that way takes a long time for
something to diffuse from one side of
the room to the other if you could pick
if you could kind of hack the molecular
structure of the of the air you could
actually go pick the correct molecule to
just ride on to get from one side of the
room to the other you could do that at
the speed of sound so it's the same kind
of idea in hacking the structure of
space
but one of the issues is okay you're
down at the level of individual atoms of
space and you're hacking things so to
speak but how do you get a thing like us
down to that level you know it's all
well and good to say well we can get
this little tiny spacecraft that
consists of three atoms of space or
something to make the jump faster than
light to somewhere else but if we're
trying to go faster than light that's a
whole different story we're very big on
the scale of the atoms of space
and it's sort of analogous to the
following thing if you imagine
that you say well i want to i want to
take a trip to a nearby galaxy
uh how am i going to do that well
there's a way to get something to make a
trip to a nearby galaxy just
shine a laser out into space and maybe a
photon or two from that laser will just
keep going and keep going keep going and
eventually we'll get to that other
galaxy
the way things work
when you go at the speed of light you're
kind of using all your computational
effort to move
and none of your computational effort
goes into the elapsing of time for you
and so time stands still that's a
phenomenon that was discovered in
relativity theory it's something which
we now have a very sort of
straightforward understanding of in our
models of fundamental physics but
essentially if you're riding on that
photon time is standing still for you
so then the question is only you say
well that's a great way to visit the
nearby galaxy you know i just i just hop
a ride on a photon
the only problem is it's profoundly not
you by the time you're reduced to a
single photon so there's sort of this
trade-off if you want an observer of
what's going on that's kind of like you
then it's tough to
stuff that into something like an
individual photon so this is a
complicated trade-off if you want to
have a thing like you that kind of kind
of experience i don't know moving across
space at a certain speed then that's
that's something that is a much
different challenge from just saying is
there anything that can propagate across
space at that speed
okay let's see
uh it was a question here
from
aaron
how much memory does a rock have
do protons or photons have memory do
orbits have memory
how much memory does a rock have well
you know here's a funny thing to say
a
semiconductor device
a chip a memory chip in your computer
what is a memory chip made of it's made
of silicon
silicon is basically the main ingredient
of rock
so in some sense
when you have a memory chip it's a very
very carefully refined piece of rock
and so that memory chip is effectively
like storing information in something
like a rock it's storing information in
the configuration of electrons that
exist there
now in a naturally occurring rock you
also have configurations of electrons
there's a question of whether there are
many different configurations that can
all exist
in that way the rock could be set up
that way the big idea of for example a
magnetic disk okay let me explain a
little bit more here
so in magnetism
what is magnetism if you have a bar
magnet or something like that what
actually is that
well
there are elementary magnets individual
atoms of iron for example have the
feature that
they
uh well actually the ultimate individual
sort of elementary magnets are things
like electrons
electrons
fundamentally are like little tiny bar
magnets they have a certain magnetic
field that they produce
and so and depend you can align an
electron the electron spin is what
determines this direction you can align
an electron to produce a magnetic field
that's like a bar magnet with its north
south orientation being wherever you
want it to be
so what you're doing in when you make a
magnetic when you have a magnetic a bar
magnet is you've got lots of little
electrons that are part of iron atoms
and so on that have all lined up to be
all in the same direction so they're all
all their magnetism is is adding up
together
and you get this thing with a big
magnetic field that corresponds to a bar
magnet
okay so that's what's called
ferromagnetism is when you have a
situation where where all the electrons
can
keep themselves all lined up
there's another thing called
ferrymagnetism
where you can have little tiny domains
where one part of the material has all
its electron spins up another one might
have all its electron spins down and so
on and you can have in very sort of fine
regions not individual electrons but
just small numbers of electrons where
everybody's lined up one way everybody's
lined up another way and so on
and for those of you who remember
magnetic tape or floppy disks and so on
or even hard disks those are ferry
magnets
those are things where there are local
regions of a material that are
magnetized one way or another way and
that's how the data is stored on
something like a floppy disk or or a
physical hard disk nowadays because of
sort of an abusive notation people call
things hard disks when they're actually
made of semiconductor memory but they
back in the day when when one always had
these spinning discs they were made of
ferrite and ferrite and each little
region of the disk will be magnetized
one way or the other representing a one
bit or a zero bit at that particular
place on the disk
so
so whenever you have something like a
ferry magnet and there are plenty of
minerals that behave as fairy magnets
you can
have something where you've got um
uh the um
um
uh the the i'm distracted here because i
realized there's a ladybug crawling on
my camera i don't know whether that's a
sign of good luck or whatever let's hope
it is
um the uh
anyway the the um
uh back back to um
back to this
so
we've got um uh so you know in something
like one of these minerals that can have
little magnetic domains pointed one way
or another you can certainly store
information so can you probably store
information in the in the detailed
structure for example actually here's a
better example
the detailed if you have a perfect
crystal where all the atoms are
perfectly lined up there's really no
information in that crystal other than
just you've got a crystal and
everything's lined up but as soon as
there are defects places where the
crystal doesn't have all its atoms
perfectly lined up
those defects can store information
now it may be more or less difficult
to actually extract the information
uh for example people people often have
cases where oh i don't know you can
write data in little you can etch things
into quartz you can have these things
called bubble memories where you're
where you're putting magnetic bubbles
into into materials and things in all of
these cases you're kind of trying to
trying to change the structure of the
material to store memory there even in
our brains most likely the synapses
between nerve cells the way that they
store memory is through the calcium
channels that exist
in uh that either do or do not permit
signals to go through
uh in but between different nerve cells
and those those channels it's as if
we're just sort of putting you know
putting little pieces of rock little
pieces of calcium like stuff um into the
the the hundred the the 100 billion uh
synapses in our you know 100 it's more
like um
a million billion synapses in our brains
um
and um
uh
no 100
10 to the 14 synapses i think which is
um about 100 trillion synapses in our
brains each one is kind of like a little
tiny piece of of rock at some level
storing memories there so the challenge
is usually the structure of material all
the detailed configuration of its atoms
can represent the storage of information
the challenge is how do you write that
information to the thing and how do you
read it out again
now this question asked also do protons
or photons have memory the answer is not
much from what we know
it seems to be the case in in current
theories of quantum mechanics and so on
it seems to be the case
that there is only a limited amount of
data associated with each individual
elementary particle in particular the
only things that one knows about
elementary particles are their momentum
and energy
and their spin direction that those are
the only um those are the only things
that characterize elementary particles
now it's a weird fact that there's one
other thing in the universe that kind of
works that way and it's black holes
black holes you kind of can only
characterize them by their total mass
their momentum perhaps and various
attributes about their angular momentum
that's essentially their spin so it's
kind of a funny coincidence that this
very big thing black holes it's very
little thing these particles are both
characterized by this limited amount of
information
kind of makes one wonder whether they're
actually the same thing and i remember
when i was some oh i don't know
probably 14 years old or something i
went to a talk given by some well-known
physicist who was talking about black
holes a long time ago when black holes
were were just sort of first really
being discussed seriously
and um was talking about this and
talking about particles and and all
those kinds of things and i went up to
him afterwards and i said you know based
on what you've said
you know
isn't is it possible that particles are
just very tiny black holes
and he's like oh no they couldn't
possibly be true you know totally
different areas of physics you know no
connection whatsoever
it'll be interesting if it turns out
that uh 50-something years later or
whatever that that turns out to be what
actually happens
and i think there is some evidence that
there is a close connection between the
way that
uh black holes are made from the
large-scale structure of space and the
way that particles might be made also
from the structure of space because you
know an electron in our models of of um
of physics
an electron
is still
many trillions of atoms of space across
it's actually pretty big
on on the scale of what happens in the
universe now your average black hole
might be an awful lot bigger because it
might be the size of a star or so it
might be kilometers across might come
from a from a whole star or something
but um uh the fact is that the the the
way in which
you get these sort of discrete kind of
let me explain what there's this kind of
idea of a topological obstruction
so for example let's say you have a
piece of string
and you've got it it's wiggling all
kinds of ways you pull on the ends of
the piece of string the piece of string
becomes taut it's just a straight line
okay let's imagine that the string is
wrapped around a pencil somewhere
then you pull on the ends and pull as
you might you'll never untie that the
string is always wrapped around that
pencil you can think of it as sort of a
topological feature of the string it's
kind of wrapped around something and
however hard you pull you're not going
to be able to unwrap it
the same thing happens in something like
a vortex in a fluid
what's happening is the the pieces of
fluid the molecules and the fluid and on
average are going around in circles
around that vortex and sort of even
though the vortex is buffeted from all
sides you kind of can't get rid of that
kind of the fact that it's swirling
around that thing the same reason that a
tornado is felt or a hurricane is fairly
stable in the earth's atmosphere you
have to kind of you have to kind of do
something that kind of jumps over that
sort of singularity in the middle to be
able to get rid of the thing
and that kind of persistence that sort
of topological stability is what is sort
of at the heart of why black holes work
it's also perhaps at the heart of why
particles can exist in space so those
might be the same kind of thing okay if
that was true what would it mean
see a black hole all you know when you
see a black hole from the outside
is kind of what it looks like from the
outside if you go near the black hole
you fall into the black hole and you
never heard from again
so in a sense the the the kind of what
we know about black hole is only what
its exterior its boundary shows us
and so there might be all kinds of
things going on inside the black hole
you know there could be all kinds of
spacecraft that have fallen through the
black hole and everybody's partying
inside and they're having a grand old
time and you know they've made a whole
civilization there and they've got uh
time is is progressing perfectly well
time will eventually stop in the black
hole that's some uh you know that's
that's kind of a
well that's a weird situation because
when time stops you don't know that time
stopped because time has stopped for you
but um uh that that's some but things
could be happening inside the black hole
but from outside the black hole there's
an event horizon we don't get to see
into the black hole we don't get nothing
from inside the black hole has any
effect on anything outside the black
hole so it could be the case the same
thing happens for particles it could be
the case that in a sense
inside your average electron there's
more stuff going on and it just one of
the things that's really a mystery about
electrons is they're all the same that's
a fundamental fact about quantum field
theory particle physics whatever you
want to call it all the electrons in the
universe are basically the same
they can have different momentum they
can go at different speeds and things
and their spin there can be oriented
differently but otherwise they're all
the same they all have a mass of you
know 0.511 mev etc et cetera they all
have all have these same characteristics
why is that well could it be the case
that from the outside so to speak they
all have the same characteristics but
were we to to be able to sort of bore
into the electron they would be
different inside we don't know and in
the idea that kind of electrons are a
little bit like very very tiny black
holes there is a sense in which there
might actually be sort of a different
structure inside different electrons and
that has a bunch of implications for all
kinds of questions about quantum
mechanics and so on although it is less
important than you might think because
we are observers
who only are sensitive to things like
what's the exterior of the electron like
so anyway the answer is i suspect in
current theories of physics know you
can't store very much information in a
single electron um
you know it's possible that if you were
to sort of if if you were to be able to
fall into an electron you might find all
sorts of other stuff there but even if
you did that you might never be able to
get out and tell anybody on the outside
so in a sense it's not useful to have
thought of one having stored information
inside there
let's see
uh
oh boy
um
oh there are many many questions here
they're very interesting all right let's
talk about
um
it's a question here from mr
when is someone considered dead how do
we define the line between alive and
dead
you know
for
i'll tell us sort of a a parable type
story
so in theory of quantum mechanics
there's
all this question about whether you only
know the probabilities of things or
whether definite things happen
and a chapter called irwin schrodinger
had this idea of kind of illustrating
sort of a thought experiment about
quantum mechanics
and he said look you know you have all
these probabilities and things but if
you have something where you have a cat
in a box and the poor cat has some
lethal thing pointed at it
then in the end the cat is either alive
or dead
and
it's kind of for him it's kind of you
can't say well there's a certain the cat
is kind of 90 alive and 10
uh dead or you know it doesn't work that
way if you imagine some small physical
system
like you said this is i don't know a a
um
uh
i don't know something is as a as a as
water that's boiling and you know some
of it is a little bit boiled but a
little bit not boiled but it could
condense again and there isn't so much
definitiveness about the water is either
turned to steam or it hasn't because you
know the steam could have droplets in it
and it could be kind of a gray area in
between
but the traditional kind of you know
when you think about a cat
it's either alive or dead
and
when you look at lower organisms
and you say
is that
uh kind of um
uh
uh tardigrade water bear a little tiny
tiny organism is that really alive or
dead it's it's hibernated it's it's on
the moon
i i'm i i'm embarrassed to say a friend
of mine was responsible for for actually
uh sort of somewhat inadvertently
spilling tardigrade tardigrades on the
moon
um
so uh
as a result of putting as a sort of
payload on um uh of kind of interesting
materials from our civilization onto a
spacecraft which unfortunately crashed
into the surface of the moon a couple of
years ago now um and one piece of what
was put in there was a little package of
tardigrades which were strewn presumably
over the surface of the moon on a small
area but the question is are they alive
or dead they are at best hibernating all
of their processes have slowed to to
nothing but
probably probably if you put them in
water again or something they would come
back to life and be happy and say what
happened over the last thousand years i
didn't notice the passage of time over
the last thousand years
now when it comes to to us humans
there are just all these systems that
work inside us
and
they are all connected together and if
you fundamentally stop them if you
fundamentally stop
uh delivering oxygen to tissues you stop
the process of metabolism tissues will
die
and tissues don't come back to to you
know they don't there's that they
actually die what does it mean to to
actually die it means you know we have
cells they've got these elaborate
machinery in them that are proteins that
are kept in some particular state
and if they die it means it's all
scrambled up the proteins are no longer
arranged in these nice forms they no
longer things are no longer sort of
sliding around and having all the
chemical reactions they're supposed to
have instead they're
they're um they've they've been sort of
you know they it's uh they've been all
scrambled up
and in fact
often
in in uh organisms like us humans
cells undergo this thing called
programmed cell death
apoptosis
and so when a cell
when a cell thinks that
it
sort of should
die for the sake of the organism
the cell
will release
these
little uh packets of essentially poison
inside the cell lysosomes that will
cause the whole cell to kind of
self-destruct and that's what happens
for example
in cases where the immune system is
going to attack cells that are infected
with viruses and so on they what what
will eventually happen will there be a
bunch of different processes but one of
the things that can happen is the cell
is kind of given the signal just
self-destruct
the same thing can happen if cells are
deprived of oxygen
things like that that cells go into this
pattern where they where they destroy
themselves
um
now
this question of sort of what does it
what counts as
an organism
being being alive well it's that all of
its standard processes are are running
you know running as they should run what
are the indicators of that happening
there's things like metabolism
uh that um uh the sort of the the
continued use of oxygen to to sort of uh
do these little
microscopic kind of burning processes
that are what generate energy for our
cells um all those kinds of things
the um uh there are also things for for
humans like uh brain activity that we
can measure things like that now when
you when you ask the question are you
are you there so to speak
that is also a question of is the brain
doing the things it should do to have
you be conscious and kind of aware of
what's going on that's a more
complicated issue because you can
imagine a situation where there's you
know of the 100 billion neurons in your
brain there are lots of neurons that are
still firing and doing things but
somehow you haven't synthesized that
together to make this sort of thread of
experience that we associate with
consciousness and in fact the brain
seems to have very definite mechanisms
for maintaining that sort of thread of
experience there are particular you know
if you talk to neurosurgeons they'll
tell you you know if you've damaged the
such and such cranial nerve
then you're you're kind of out of luck
you don't seem to be able to synthesize
that kind of thread of experience that's
associated with kind of our typical
conscious experience of the world
so there's sort of very detailed
properties of the brain that seem to be
necessary to synthesize kind of our view
of the world it's it's kind of as if uh
you could say well i've got a little
piece of brain tissue here and it's got
neurons firing and doing things but it
isn't really it's not really aware of
the world because it doesn't have this
kind of notion of a threat of experience
that we seem to have
now you know could you imagine that it's
like an alien species where you've got a
little piece of brain
and it's having all kinds of things
happen in it it's having sort of quotes
thoughts but they're not thoughts that
we can align with our usual notion of
kind of conscious experience
so so that gets a little complicated and
i think that the um
this question of um
uh
of of kind of what
under what circumstances what does it
mean
you know that there are other things
with with uh with humans of of how much
is a human sort of independently able to
to be walking around sort of doing
things independently and to what extent
do you have to have technology
that
is
serving the place of various kinds of
human organs
and those kinds of things and that's a
that's another sort of criterion for
whether it's a it's a kind of a a
complete live human and so on but my
guess is that in fact in the future that
this this sort of
this border between the sort of what's
fully alive and what's not and so on
it's going to get more and more
complicated um and i think the one thing
that is really
seems to be a dividing line is this kind
of thread of experience kind of idea and
whether that's being maintained or not
and
the question of you know what happens
when that thread of experience can be
converted to something which is
essentially a digital version of the
same thing
where where the main sort of activity of
the neurons is being driven not by other
neurons but by some technological device
then this becomes a very complicated
question
so i think i i think that's that's about
as much as i could say about that right
now i think that the this whole question
about um
whether
uh
you know in some sense
this sort of is the organism dead or
alive for typical big organisms and
typical situations
that's very sort of easy to answer but
it gets a lot more complicated like for
example let's imagine that we could
freeze an organism right now what
happens if you try and you know freeze
a uh
something the size of a person
there's this horrible problem that water
is a fairly unique in this respect it's
a substance that gets bigger when it
freezes ice is a lower density than
liquid water in other words for a given
mass of of water
as ice it occupies larger volume than it
does as liquid water and so that means
that when you freeze something with lots
of water in it as as we have
then the then things will expand and for
us that will be really bad news because
our cells will just explode because they
have little pieces of ice in them and so
you know there's a whole bunch of
technology when you get water down to a
sufficiently low temperature i think
it's 44 degrees
minus 44 degrees celsius
you end up
getting into this kind of glassy state
that's a form of solidified
water that isn't like the crystallized
structure of ice and it doesn't have
this property of getting bigger
but uh the you know eventually there
might come a time when you can like
freeze organisms and and there are there
are some kinds of fish that successfully
get frozen over the winter um you know
in ice and there's sort of the question
is the frozen fish alive or dead
you know the frozen fish is really
frozen like nothing's moving it's a
solid it's not you know a lot of what
dry what makes us work is we're very
liquid state creatures
there's a it's not quite liquid it's
more like a gel
um but it's we're using the fact that we
can have these sort of flowing materials
inside cells and so on if we're like
frozen solid none of those processes
work anymore and there's the question of
is the frozen fish alive or dead and you
know i think that's a that's a
complicated question of what you choose
to
make the words mean uh the fish can be
you know when you heat the fish up again
it's a happy fish swimming around um and
uh
that um if we're lucky that might be
possible for humans too at some point
all right let me see
ah
question um
um
let's see
um
well
uh
okay there's a question here from zero d
how do a flock of sparrows know how to
change directions simultaneously
so you know it's a feature
of flux of birds schools of fish
you know you see this big collection of
birds
and
they're all going in one direction and
then they change direction start going
in a different direction same with
schools of fish how does that work
well
there's a
what seems to the best we know about
that
has to do with models that can be made
computational models that can be made
there's a class of models called boyds
boids
that uh
invented by a chap called craig reynolds
originally for
for making things like flocks of bats
and movies and i think it was a batman
movie that was i'm not sure if that was
actually the first one but uh was
certainly one where voids were used
so how do these computational models
work
well the idea is you have a bunch of
organisms and each organism
kind of has conceited to both sides of
the organism
and
then all it's doing is it's looking
locally around it at who's nearest to it
and then it's sensing
kind of what those nearest things near
it are doing and it has a couple of
parameters about sort of how how how
much it tries to align its direction
with the directions of its neighbors and
so on but essentially what's happening
is it's a little bit like what happens
in a magnet for example where where all
the electrons eventually line up
when as soon as
that
bird likes to be aligned with its
neighboring bird you've got sort of a
force that tends to make all the birds
turn together
now
depending on how you
set up the parameters it turns out
there's a large range of parameters
where fundamentally the flock of birds
is going to stay together now the
question is what makes the flock change
direction to begin with
well there's typically a lead bird and i
don't know
what causes the lead bird to suddenly
say i'm fed up with going in this
direction i'm going to change direction
i don't think that's known
um and it's an interesting question
what is the sort of generator of
randomness in the brain of a bird or a
fish or something that causes it to
suddenly decide okay time's up i'm gonna
change direction
um it's there are some mechanisms in
brains that are understood about how
sort of uh
decisions get made so very very simple
example
uh walking for instance there's a
you can it's a pretty low level function
inside brains to keep kind of keep the
legs walking back and forth
um you don't need sort of uh elaborate
conscious thinking to be able to do that
it's kind of like you can just without
really thinking about it if you're on
treadmill or even if you have some some
terrible experiment with an animal where
where most of its brain isn't isn't
isn't there it'll still walk on the
treadmill so to speak
and um that it's usually called in the
kind of literature of these things the
central pattern generator it's a it's a
kind of a a circuit made of neurons that
actually has this property that it is
generating this kind of wave of activity
that just has one left foot right foot
left foot right foot and so on so that's
a case where it's kind of knowing what
the kind of neural circuit that leads to
activity is there's probably something
like that that is the sort of generator
of randomness that leads to that oh it
times up i'm going to go in this
different direction but it's not known
what that is
it's actually one of the weird features
in terms of birds
is uh uh you know how do birds know
which way to go how do pigeons know how
to go home things like that i remember
years ago uh there's a was a funny paper
that i think is correct um that
basically says you know in the end
pigeons often remember the the pattern
of roads and that's how they're how
they're sort of following the roads to
to figure out how to go from here to
there presumably before there were roads
they were following other kinds of
landmarks
pigeons actually seem to have another
weird feature which is pigeons directly
seem to sense the earth's magnetic field
so you know the earth that's how a you
know a compass and magnetic compass
works
is the earth has a magnetic field
produced by currents in the earth's
mantle that um uh has a a so the the
compass needle will align itself with
the direction of the earth's magnetic
field and it turns out the pigeons seem
to have a direct mechanism a direct sort
of uh organ in their brains that that
can sense magnetic fields
and it's becoming a little bit clearer
how that works and it's kind of a tricky
thing it is a very thing that depends
very much on having
individual atoms that will align
themselves to the field of the of the
who's whose little little spins will
align themselves to the direction of
earth's magnetic field and there's a
whole mechanism to sort of read out
the um uh this this very detailed kind
of atomic scale feature of um of of of
these atoms essentially what's happening
is normally the spin direction of an of
a of the okay the
this is um
uh
yeah let me think about this for a
second this is
usually the direction of the spin
has no direct effect on things about
chemistry it has an implicit effect
because that's what
causes one to be able to fill up
electron shells and things like that for
chemistry but it has no direct effect
and what happens is there are these
situations in which one has seems to
have a direct
chemical effect of spin directions
through particular structures of
molecules and so on and that's what
seems to happen in the in the brains of
pigeons
let's see
um
okay there's a question here from
quantum do i think it's more important
for humanity to look to colonize another
planet or to look after the earth and
make it more habitable in the future
you know i i do have to say that one of
the things i think people get a little
bit confused by
is if you look at the history of earth
its climate for example has changed
dramatically over over the years over
very long periods of time often but even
shorter periods of time even in the
1600s there was a little ice age and you
know places where it's pretty pretty
warm in the summer nowadays were very
cold all year round even the 1600s so
not long ago
and there are these cycles that are to
do with the earth's orbit there are
other cycles um there are a variety of
their cycles perhaps even in the amount
of radiation produced by the sun there
are all kinds of things that affect
things like the temperature of the
surface of the earth the amount of
oxygen in the earth's atmosphere the
amount of carbon dioxide etc etc etc
we humans
are having an effect on all of that
whether our effect is large compared to
what is naturally there well that's a
whole complicated debate but assume that
it is fairly large it's still the case
that you know one can expect that the
climate of the earth and so on will
change over time the question is what do
you do about it
and you can you can say well you know
i want the i want to you know turn back
the clock i want to make the earth be
just like it was when dinosaurs were
around
probably bad for us i don't think i
forget what sea level was like in the
time of the dinosaurs but things were
very different then um and i think um uh
it's um
it's a uh um it's one of these things
that i've sort of wondered why are
people
uh in the past you know
a millennium ago whatever else
there were these changes of of climate
and all kinds of things on the earth
why did people seem to pay
make less of a big deal out of that then
than now
well part of the answer is that you know
if things change over 100 years and
you're farming one piece of land and
you're basically kind of nomadic and now
you're going to farm another piece of
land it isn't that big a deal if you've
built a very fancy city and with all
kinds of skyscrapers and you it's right
by the ocean and it's beautiful beach
front property and so on and suddenly
sea level not suddenly over the course
of 50 years 100 years 200 years sea
level changes
um then it's like oh my gosh my
skyscraper is is not going to be worth
as much or is going to you know have to
have a dyke built around it or some such
other thing
and you know in a sense by building up
all of the things we have in the modern
world we've made things a bit more
fragile than they were before and so
that's kind of a you know it's it's a
it's a feature of progress that that's
happened you know one can have all kinds
of discussions about okay well we've got
that kind of progress what about doing
geoengineering to you know change the
effect of this or that or the other on
the earth
uh you know what do we do to um uh to
sort of change
what um uh you know whether whether we
put more carbon dioxide in the
atmosphere or don't uh clearly there are
uh
you know better
you know one of the things that's a bit
confusing about about modern sort of
questions about this there was a time
when was it in the 70s i guess 1970s
when there was this problem with ozone
which is what blocks ultraviolet light
from the sun there was this sort of hole
in the ozone layer in the upper
atmosphere that was developing that was
traced to being associated with the kind
of propellant cfcs that were used for
aerosol cans and so people said let's
let's get rid of cfcs and use something
different for aerosol propellants and by
golly that had exactly the effect you
would expect and you know the ozone hole
i think disappeared and everybody was
happy turns out it's more difficult
it seems to be more difficult
to get rid of some of these other things
that are sort of random side effects of
technology maybe there'll be ways found
to get rid of those more easily and it
won't be a big deal but if it had been
the case that people said okay no more
aerosols that will be you know no more
spray cans of anything uh you know that
might not have been a good thing there
are plenty of medical purposes and so on
for which those are used and that would
be bad but turned out there was an
alternative technology wasn't so
difficult to implement and so all was
good
but so you know there's this sort of
question of you know what technological
solutions you know we we it's a side
effect of technology that things are
happening there's something that's going
to happen anyway we have to kind of
decide how do we feel about sort of the
earth changing anyway are we going to
say no no we want to lock it down you
know the earth as it was in in whenever
pick your date i want the earth to
always be that way well actually you
know we'd have to really change what's
happening in the earth i mean you know
for example the rotation of the earth is
slowing down by you know milliseconds
per per year or something and it's like
well that will mean that at some point
you know the length of the day will be
measurably different
oh you know we could say we don't like
that let's speed up the rotation of the
earth kind of why why bother
turns out it doesn't seem to matter much
to sort of everyday life
there are things that do seem to matter
more to everyday life and those we might
care more about not having sort of go
out of kilter but that's sort of a
trade-off because you say well you know
in order to uh
in order to get um
uh the way that we want
the the the earth to be
we need to
uh to do all these elaborate things i
mean it's kind of like like there are
things we want to do to kind of lead our
lives that are enabled by technology
there are things that sort of there are
side effects of that technology we can
fix that and so on but we kind of have
to have to uh decide how much we want to
sort of distort the things that we
have been made able to do
uh for the sake of things where we don't
even know necessarily what the
consequences are going to be and so on
so you know complicated issues but you
know the the best situation is when it
just turns out it's an easy
technological fix
and perhaps we'll get more of those
perhaps we'll get fusion power for
example which will be an easy
technological fix potentially i remember
when i was a kid in england
um one of the things that was an issue
was there had been a lot of pollution in
around cities there still isn't in many
countries there's lots of pollution
around cities um from power plants and
so on and factories belching out stuff
into into the air well you know people
said no no you can't do that you know
put filters and and uh et cetera et
cetera et cetera and turned out what
just wasn't that difficult to do
similarly to to clean up rivers and so
on by not you know by putting filters
before you dump stuff into rivers and
turned out in a period of a decade or
two
things became you know it was no longer
polluted in london it was no longer you
know the thames river was no longer a
totally polluted thing that was
comparatively easy technologically and
it wasn't a oh my gosh to achieve this
technologically we have to completely
change the quality of life so to speak
so you know one can i think
an important place to push is on these
sort of technological fixes which may be
obvious maybe easy may not be so obvious
may require more technology to achieve
and so on and also to ask the question
what is it that one wants to achieve in
the end you know one of the things that
we may be able to do eventually people
have been wondering about this for
for forever is can we control the
weather can we control local weather
like you know it rained where i am today
um and oh i really wanted to go for a
walk could i have uh you know pressed
some buttons and made it be the case
that no it wouldn't rain where i am and
um uh you know it would be controllable
but the question where if you say you
control the weather is okay but the
weather it's not just about me going out
for my walk you know there's lots of
other people who live near here too and
you know how do they feel about what the
weather should be it becomes a very
complicated question once you can make
these kinds of uh changes that have sort
of a global effect you know how do you
make the decision about what to do and
then it becomes a complicated kind of
socio-political question
but the question is also what about
colonizing other planets
well you know one of the problems is
that we humans with the particular
biology we have we just spent three
billion years evolving for this
particular planet that we're on with all
its various changes and ice ages and
this and that and the other but
fundamentally we're evolved for this
planet and if you say okay let's go even
to mars or venus you know the planets
are different and
maybe we can terraform maybe mars maybe
venus
we can make it so that those planets
will have atmospheres somewhat similar
to our own
although their gravities will be
slightly different because they're
different sized planets and so on uh
it's an interesting question again
if you say you know it's the ultimate
kind of environmental effects question
um you say oh you know we shouldn't uh
build a city in this forest because
we'll be destroying a bunch of forest
you say should we build a city on mars
and should we change the whole
atmosphere of planet mars to be more
human-friendly
well you might say it's just a piece of
rock
and so far as we know mars is just a
piece of rock there's no life there
there's nothing we think is important
but there is rock there right now we
don't have any qualms about saying we'll
change the the the environment for the
rock if there was if there was a life
there and we had little little creatures
crawling around we might say look at
those cute little creatures sprawling
around on mars we don't want to destroy
their habitat um
we don't right now we have no evidence
for life on mars at least right now um
and uh
and recognizing what life is and is
similar to life on earth that's a whole
complicated issue in its own right but
this whole question about do we feel
that we should go
and uh you know just change the you know
change the universe well we're changing
the universe locally here on earth so
there's an argument why not just extend
that and start changing it on other
planets in our solar system or whatever
but but assume we did that um and that's
a very very difficult thing to do not
obvious whether it would work not
obvious how to do it from a physics
point of view and so on
um there's still you know it's still
going to be a big nuisance let's say to
live on mars just as
you know people don't live under the
oceans because it's a big nuisance to do
that people don't live uh you know in
antarctica because it's a big nuisance
to do that we are evolved for those
areas of our planet where
we've been involved to live
and um the uh you know to get to a
different place with our current
evolutionary uh characteristics with our
current biological characteristics is
not an easy thing to do and you might
say well gee you know over a
sufficiently long time why don't we just
evolve into a different form but then
then it's kind of like well what are you
trying to achieve i mean by the time you
have the computer that is running a
digital version of me that's sitting in
a colo and a co-location facility on
mars it's like what have we exactly
achieved here um it's uh you know is
that really is that really a direction
we want to achieve
um all right i probably uh
there's a question here about can we
um
uh
um
push jet streams on on the earth you
know the jet stream is this uh high
altitude rapid wind that uh goes around
um uh in the northern and southern
latitudes um
and uh there's a sort of question of of
what aspects of the earth's atmosphere
and the flow of air in the atmosphere
are somehow unstable what fraction of
those things are very robust and
whatever you do you can't really perturb
them and which ones are sort of
sensitive and if you could just put the
right thing in the right place at the
right time you would suddenly flip that
ocean current or that uh uh that current
in the that wind um
uh stream of wind in the air to go in a
different direction i don't know and
that's an interesting question to ask
for climate models and things to what
extent there is stability those are
those will be difficult questions to
answer because the way these models are
set up they are they're very s
there's a big issue of validating the
models and they're questions about
stability of the of the underlying
methods that are used on a computer to
make those models work and probably a
certain amount of hackery is being done
there but i know it's being done there
to um that will make it a little bit
difficult to answer these sensitivity
questions but it's an interesting
question i don't know the answer for the
specifics of actual current climate
models
all right i had better go now uh i have
to something else i have to do right now
but um thanks for those questions i see
we have lots of interesting ones uh
queued up ready for same time next week
look forward to uh
seeing you there